[Music]
this is a big story i'm gonna drop a big
bomb on you i love the bahamas i i
dropped a bomb ham on you did you say
you love the bahamas just to use that
pun no i just i shouldn't brag about
this this is really lame but i just it's
a dad joke you're a fatherless person
who does a lot of dad jokes
yeah
uh people might think i'm a dad because
of all the dad jokes i do but i'm not uh
but um you know what i miss right now uh
ever since my little trip to the bahamas
recently is uh conch
i missed the flavor of conk in my mouth
um conk for those of you who don't know
who aren't in the know
is a mollusk that is found it's a
beautiful shell it's you probably know
it from its shell it's uh just one of
you know those big shelves when you want
to listen to the ocean you want to hear
the ocean you put it to your ear it's
those big beautiful shells and um the
mollusk inside is i hate i'm sorry
animal lovers
uh it's delicious it looks sweet
you have to tenderize it yeah i made it
once i made it in place of clams for
clams like linguine and um yeah i had to
beat the hell out of it with a hammer
not well it was alive but
you are supposed to it's tasty you're
supposed to eat it when it's 11. and the
best way to do it is um well i went to a
place called the conch queen shout out
to lavonne yeah
queen in harbor island oh man lavon uh i
hate to even say this because i don't
want her shack to be even more popular
than it is and i say shaq not
disparagingly it really is a shack it's
but it's they make the
best conch ceviche and it's moving as
she as they cut it out oh boy i know
let's uh let's
let's conk
could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to the life is short
i'm your a conch loving host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is our mother it's
our mother might be our third uh host
here she is let's put her on
christian's putting her on hi mom
hi honey christian do you have a um
today
no elements design no
what's elements design
it's a place i get massages at
and but how you didn't want to say that
the question is how do you
why do you think that i might have an
appointment
me something on today message that i
have a
four four forty five appointment and
elements
maybe i i have
i have an appointment at 4 45 on
thursday
not today though weird this is strange
you got an email
not an email a message
what kind of message
passenger pigeon
like a text
oh that's strange all right well i'll
try to get to the bottom of it uh let me
call you back hey mom
hey mom do you want to be on life is
short
too late
you guys look very pro well we are we're
pros we have a we have a pro we're pro
podcasters wow with real microphones
how do you think we do it you just yell
on an old casio
how are you feeling justin um i'm i'm
okay all right we'll talk to you later
we're in the middle of this
oh oh okay okay bye
say hi hi
bye
i wonder what that is what were we
talking about conch before our
oh you know conk
uh the current jeopardy champion is
named lawrence long you love him you're
going to look i want to see how much it
relates because
we are going to look for any reason to
talk about this okay he's my dream yeah
pretty contestant
he is efficient what does that mean your
dream jeopardy like if you were to
explain okay sorry his last name is long
yeah first of all arrogant he is
not arrogant but it relates to me yeah
he has great penmanship he is he is um
he's a great mustache he's dry he's very
dry-witted
and his story on the first night
he's a conk player what yeah what does
that mean
he can play you know
yes no kidding yeah that's that's how it
relates oh that's cool i'm sorry to the
complex yeah yeah anyway why are we
talking about conch
because our guest today is known for
playing one of the most famous shells in
the world a shell character called
marcel marcel the shell it was a
internet phenomenon you can so rarely
say that it internet phenomenons like
viral hits are usually reserved for
people who didn't i think
i would didn't mean to do it like the
grape stomp lady grape stuff i would
love to talk to her
or um antoine dodson
you know hide your wife kids
or the winnebago man they made a
documentary but but but yes you're right
um
all people who didn't really ask for
infamous yes they didn't ask for the
thing but she asked for it she created
this little yes yes it's such a great
video and now it's at south by southwest
i just saw she they made a movie about 8
24 i think which is the you know if
you're going to make a movie make it
with 8 24 or lionsgate
shout out um and so there's a movie
version of marcel the shell our guest is
the very talented not just voice actress
actress in general she's got another
movie called i want you back out she's a
great writer jenny slade
very very funny he's slated to be our
guest yes she
she was also the star star of a great
movie called obvious child
um a number of years really good actress
great actress um really funny and she
was on snl for a period yeah but it's
really known for like post snl stuff and
she's now she's in the middle we talk
about her she's writing her second book
um she's just such a talented such an
easy like charming person she kind of
does it all right she's like what's the
equivalent of a jack of all trades
of all trades oh yeah uh
huh a jacqueline of all trades
jacqueline maybe of all trades but
that you know they should have that they
absolutely should now i'm trying to
think of the male version of jenny's she
does a lot of improv she had a she had a
very well known like cool indie
show that live show that she did for
years in new york she had like a cool
she's like she's cool yeah and she's um
oh big mouth she's a great
such great voices um you know you're a
good voice actor when i saw an episode
of conan where he said
how do you do it how did you come up
with that voice uh marcel is one of the
best and
she's she's just such a lovely person
i've always
i've run into over the years and always
so enjoyed seeing her and it's usually
at like kind of an uncomfortable
hollywood thing uh and so i i love
finding her and and connecting with her
there and so let's hear from her yeah
okay let's hear me reconnect with her um
and uh here she is the the very charming
very funny smart sweet jenny slate
life could be
[Music]
okay officially on okay officially on
okay
so right now she's sleeping so it's fine
yeah and are you are you feeling like
when she is sleeping when you are away
what does that feel like friend for a
new
mom i will never know right that's true
um yeah prob not not at least you'll
never know in this way yeah but um
you know what it's like just time is
different it's and and you can't just
like jump from one thing to another
it's um like
you know people are like well in the you
know in the 40 minutes of the baby's
napping just like take time for you and
it's like
yeah let me tell you like it takes me 27
minutes just to like calm down and stop
whatever is happening in my mind and
then i sit around for 10 minutes and i
panic that i only have just 10 minutes
like do something then i do like i pee
and then it's over
yeah that's exactly what that's almost
to the word what my friend said who
had uh he has not two but when he had
yeah they were a couple months old his
his wife was like you know he had been
taken care of because his wife had been
working she's a great cinematographer
and she said when she was done with her
job she had um he had some time off and
she said well why don't you take
the take like two hours
um which she would accomplish a lot and
he said he said the same thing he's like
you you scramble you watch a little tv
and you get overwhelmed with like the
possibilities of that time and then it's
over yeah
it's really not like it's just it's just
different from before and it's not um
it's not a complaint and i i do like i
feel like i want to be really careful of
not like just kind of like complaining
or something because
um because i think that can be hurtful
uh even if like my daughter were to hear
this years later because like definitely
you know like
having her is like truly and
it sounds like a a lie but it's it's
like the
happiest i've ever been the most
the best the most positive like the
sweet most sweetness but like my husband
and i are really tired and she you know
she's like not a good she doesn't go to
bed um very well but i i think she's
getting better but like
it's just
like
it's
even if you have a let's say we had a
nanny for like all day one day which we
don't have um that whole day would be
spent for me just being like making
weird lists and like like all it just
you know like it's not
i don't know yeah no i know i'd be
overwhelmed with with what to do with
that time also you can say some if she
is listening to this years later
you can tell her you can balance it out
by saying you know you've already said i
know a little bit of how happy it made
you but you can tell her how great the
years have been yeah and and they
definitely have it's just the other
thing is like
i didn't know this about myself until
i shared my life with a baby but i'm
like
a crazy control freak about neatness and
tidying
ah oh my god yeah that must conflict
with it's really hard because there will
be like a dirty diaper on like a
beautiful sofa that i bought when i was
single
myself
yeah it's really hard
so you have to that's what an adjustment
what do you do did you do you just
breathe through it do you see the diaper
and you think i brew through the diaper
i put it on my face and i breathe
through it and i say admit to your
reality admit admit to it this this is
real life yeah your your struggle is
what's making you suffer just stop
gripping just breathe the diaper breathe
a diaper
it's her it's you love her you love all
of her i love her so much and actually i
like changing diapers like a lot
oh really in a weird way but like it's
so cute and like
it's not like you're on the f train in
brooklyn and like there's a [ __ ] and you
have to clean up you don't know where it
came from it's probably from like a man
it's like a baby you have to so you take
you would take the liberty of cleaning
up a poop on the frame there's
absolutely no way there's absolutely no
way
there's no way
but i love it it's a difference yeah
it's a different odor too i remember
because i've changed a few baby diapers
yeah
yeah my nephew and when i was little
when i was a teenager i babysat i can't
believe they trusted me i don't want to
say their names because it might be
borderline neglect negligence
when i was like 14 or 15 i watched it
like a like a six or seven month old
uh-huh like a like an infant yeah
like a young um
and so i remember that yeah i know that
smell it's pretty uh there's a sweetness
to it yeah
like when they're just drinking breast
milk they just make like stupid weird
like pumpkin colored nothing you know
it's like not a big deal which i've
literally it's like a soup yeah yeah
it's like a soup that's right which will
change how you feel about like a bisque
come fall
like i think i won't have the crab and
squash bisque i think
forget the celeriac and
root vegetable puree thanks
no thank you
what jenny why are why are you speaking
of poop why are you in l.a
i came here to yeah to take a [ __ ] no i
don't
you know i can't get any privacy in
massachusetts no um i
i'm we come here in uh i still have a a
house here um and a lovely little old
house that i bought when i was
single before i met ben and um was my
husband and
so and ben's brother lives here with his
wife and baby
um
so we just come in the winter time
um to not be so cold because we can
because ida doesn't go to school yet
that's that's not so so when she does
uh well you don't know yet i mean this
is future surfing as um
i've recently right her i love that term
i don't know if you've heard that but i
keep i find myself doing it all the time
i was like right like i heard it but i
actually unders i understood it but i
have not heard it before
well it's a thing that i'm prone to
doing i guess because i keep now i'm
conscious of it i keep catching myself
doing it but um
when she is of age would to go to school
would you
do you think you'd stay in l.a or move
back back to the east coast i think east
coast for sure
because you're from mass right you're
from i am
yeah
what was that was that a
would you describe it as like a typical
suburban upbringing
milton
boston yeah it's just it's six miles
south of boston it it's very new
englandy like there are some towns that
they
they do feel like sort of more
styled suburban like more
cul-de-sacs and developments and stuff
like that and milton um
well you know it does have it's like an
older it's an older town yeah it's new
england d it's uh
it it looks more like the like conquered
or like the witches of eastwick or
whatever yes yes i i grew up in a
similar they're like
there's some um
gravestones from like the 60 you know
that are yeah that are barely legible um
1600s uh is ben from there as well is he
in east coast he's from south coast mass
like near the rhode island border and
that's where we live now and he owns the
general store in our town
oh no yeah he does oh man it's like a
it's like a homework movie if it rules
and you know what sometimes i get afraid
and this is like the jewish in me um
but i'm just like this is
it's like have you ever seen the start
of practical magic the the sandra
bullock and nicole kidman movie where
they're witches
no i know the movie i have not seen it
she has this like husband and she just
loves them so much and their life is
perfect and like
she has like the curse i can't even say
it it doesn't matter um but no i'm not i
don't see it
oh because it's you're afraid you have a
courage i'm just i'm just like that wow
this is um it's just what i like it's
just what i want
but i guess i've earned it you know
for sure i'm not like 25.
like that's turned 40.
i feel like our paths have crossed and
we've um
commiserated in between breakups sir i i
remember talking to you at a party at it
this is sounds so prolly witty but it
might have been sundance even it was
like
some party about like in between i think
we were both maybe in between but i
don't know and just commiserating about
like being out and
meeting people and yeah it's so hard
yeah just the worst
but yeah so i'm glad i'm so happy to
hear that you that it worked out i found
it yeah have you found it what's
happening for you i don't know anything
about your personality i found it she's
um was that your partner your wife your
girlfriend yeah she she's my girlfriend
is um
also my my i.t support
i actually i've been shooting this thing
in utah jenny so i i flew out similarly
like i i can't i even though i grew up
in connecticut i can't i can't stand the
cold anymore yes um
you know two weeks in the winter
it's bad start climbing the walls yeah
um so
uh i'm visiting her on the
all
weekend
which is why
i failed to bring the little toggle that
goes into this
microphone into new computers because i
don't have a new computer um me neither
but she she's but it's the kind of thing
which i'm sure you've experienced with
ben where like um
you know that you always i i've always
heard that like when you know you know
and you meet that person you'll know and
um it just was so clear right away which
is nice so nice so nice i remember
sitting with do you know do you know
jane levy and may whitman do you know
those gals i know
may a little bit from an ex
they were friends um but not in years
have i seen me well she's only getting
better but um she's a perfect person i
don't have funny and sassy and like
she's the best she's she's incredible um
but anyway i was sitting with them like
two weeks after we started dating and
this isn't my deal i'm not like an
extreme person
um but i was like
if he asked me to marry him now i would
i get it i find myself saying things
that i've always been so afraid to say
um commitment-wise
that just comes so
naturally just kind of spill out of my
mouth that's so nice
it's nice yeah um and so did he was he
he must have been on the same page
obviously eventually but do you think
have you talked to him about his
the process i mean how quickly he fell
for you
i don't know i mean i don't know
weirdly even though i felt that way i i
um which is this is very different but
for me but like i just really kept it to
myself
um yes yeah because i think i was at it
it was important you kind of like it's
like just
i am really starting to understand like
listen just because you feel something
and maybe you think it's very precious
you actually don't need to transmit it
like across the world and
um thing to say during your pandemic but
um but like
yeah don't use transmit don't spread do
that but i uh
i remember being like the thing is this
isn't like a
like i mean he's a very handsome
brilliant person and there's a lot of
ways to feel
uh lit up and passionate about him but i
remember being like
the point is
and it's not cynical but like the point
is you feel so healthy
and beautiful about your set of feelings
and about this person who you see as who
is real who is not like doesn't mean
something to you or isn't a vehicle to a
different part in your of your life that
you're hoping to get to like they're
just alive and so like let yourself be
alive and let your feelings be happening
now and like just keep going and i think
we both were so
he has said to me that i was like
because we met and we were both like i'm
never gonna get in a relationship again
it's just it's just like not worth it
and we had talked about it and we were
just friends and
and he said that i was like a horse
whisperer
yeah
that's what's in it like i helped yeah
like unspook him that i was like
oh my god that's funny yeah you know and
i didn't mean to be that way but i think
part of it was being like
just enjoy it but i also did just enjoy
it yeah like some extreme stuff like i
you know we had been dating for
maybe like a month and a half and it was
christmas time and he lived in amsterdam
at the time and he was like oh i wish
you know we could spend christmas
together and i was like yeah i'll come
there and he was like
what
and then
i kind of pushed past like maybe this is
weird
and was just like like i can afford the
ticket and i'm jewish i don't celebrate
christmas i'm not letting anyone down
over here
you know
yeah
and there was no way that i was gonna be
like
i came here like what is this like we
need to decide what this is
that's so comforting i know how he feels
i i
there's something really comforting
about the
uh especially when you push past those
you know you have a history of like well
if i make a move like that it means this
or that right you know if i if i do this
you get these attachments to like
certain parts of the process but i i
realized that so much of that was
attached to people that i wasn't i
didn't really
enjoy enough to want to right with
there's there's something so simple and
satisfying about like
even being on location shooting i never
wanted people to come visit me when i
was shooting i was like that's my job
that's one thing i
um and
and that's changed i just
because i think it is what you said it's
just it's an understanding that you
enjoy somebody you enjoy being around
somebody yeah it's so nice
it's really that like one of um ben's
friends
had a breakup and he was like i don't
know like maybe i don't maybe i just
like don't know what it is to be in love
like you know what what would you say it
is and i was like i think it's
that when that other is there
that they just make everything a little
sweeter
yes
yes like a a total support yeah and i
mean i'm really like i do i i don't tire
of ben at all he really
but he's my very favorite but i i
haven't had a favorite like that before
um it's yeah special stuff
it is and and um it's interesting when
you say about transmitting like that
feeling that need to like transmit a any
feeling that you have any any like
from ideas to something funny to in this
case like a love like a new relay there
there is and i'm sure it's only going to
get exponentially more so
this i i this
need this this desire to like share
everything and
i kind of stopped
feeling that too um
not just with social media but with like
even
friends you know speaking too soon and
just enjoying the thing just kind of
like
taking the taking the ride oh for sure
with that person a lot of that for me
that restraint or whatever you want to
call this just like being
being less drunk
yeah
yeah
is this like that where a lot of
sharing
when a lot of sharing happens i think so
i mean i'm a happy happy
drunk but like
i just not i just i'm i just like don't
you know i mean ben and i will like have
a beer
last night um some people from our movie
because we had all been testing and
testing and testing for kovad because we
were doing our press junkets
um it was nice that we got to like
actually sit around a table and like
drink a bottle of wine but like before i
met ben like i i had quit smoking pot
and was just like sort of
heading towards a
i started choking oh did you
are you against that that's wild news i
am shocked
[Music]
[Music]
compelled you to do then i just didn't
like my lifestyle at all
i got super paranoid i i was like i
don't enjoy this i
i'm not taking myself to a better place
i'm
i'm just stagnant and it's gross and for
me i felt i just i was not i was so
panicked and paranoid all the time i
could not find a
anything that worked for me in the like
now i'm kind of interested in like the
sort of michael paul pollan
microdose psilocybin thing
yes he had me too that's exactly what he
was on the show talking about he was did
you read he was yeah his last book is um
this is your mind on plants
oh it's
yeah and he was talking all about it so
i he got me really um
intrigued and ayahuasca might be a
little too extremely scared yeah yes i i
because i've heard
for every like you know um
really positive experience i've heard
there's also been a nightmarish one yeah
one that people are like well six months
later i started having like
night terrors
it's also the um speaking of your
daughter it's the just uh it's the
pooping it's the totally like the
vomitorium or whatever nothing yes with
the shaman like i don't i don't unless
that unless i'm good friends with the
shaman uh i i don't think i feel
comfortable
expelling no those kind of bodily fluids
i mean part of it for me i was like i'm
just
i like actually i i guess i mean i've
not i don't i'm not like an addict-y
person luckily i don't have that in me
and but i did sort of just like
i just felt like i did hit a low point
where i was like i drink too much i am
you know it's it's not a big deal i
drink just as much as my friends but for
me it's too much and i don't like i
would love the like um
you know twice a year really well
thought out set and setting you know um
mushroom trip or something like that um
but
other than that i just i just can't deal
anymore my anxiety was too bad
and my
feelings about my where my life was at
were too constant like shoot just so
much constant judgment that i was like
should probably reboot what jen what was
that centered what what did that focus
on that kind of judgment was it was it
career stuff was it um
it was it just general
uh i'm not in a place i want to be in
yeah that's it
not career like i mean
career is so weird to me i don't even
know what it is
i've heard you talk about it in an
interesting way we're like
there's a great quote for you
it might be making the rounds games on
instagram or something where it was like
i am we basically say that it's weird i
i don't think people knew what to do
with me and so oh god
no i don't know i don't know i say that
only because it popped up on my
instagram i'm like that's a quote i
um it was about um
your place in the industry yeah and how
you've come you found peace uh with that
with that and how people in the past
have not known
koi what to do with you for sure and you
know what sucks about that is like part
of it just played into like feelings i
had since middle school just like and i
asked am i ugly
like am i just like straight up on
attractiveness is it that is it like is
it just that is it that
you know is it
is it i'm not cool like i'm just not
inspiring like what is it and then
recently i just got new agents and they
were like i don't know we think you're
great so now i'm like i don't know well
cool let's let's just see about it
because they think that um you know
there's a lot out there but i but
actually i don't i was i'm really
particular i don't want to go to work on
something that seems boring to me i've
short attention span
um and
you know you ever think like two weeks
in am i gonna be happy i i sometimes
wait jobs like that
like i could do it for a week maybe but
two weeks in how am i gonna feel about
like
this this thing that i'm doing for sure
and you know what i'm like i'm careful
with my my money i don't i
i don't i own a home but like other than
that i'm not like everything i spend now
it's like on my daughter's
stuff you know the baby stuff
yeah are you or do you think you'll
spoil her do you think you'll um get her
too many things i think i already have
gotten her too many things
yeah like tchotchke's like little like
things to keep her occupied like my
whole
the room that used to be like just like
the reading room in my house which is
like the biggest luxury is that like
there's one room that like has just has
books in it and
you know that is now filled with like
montessori toys
that they're just like all wooden and
they're like your baby puts the ball in
the hole and you're like
i guess so
one of those old-fashioned just like the
things you the balls the the circles you
push down the street there's like wheels
the old-fashioned um
i i
i think i would want to err on the side
of like old-fashioned stuff i think my
my big fear would be
them uh embracing technology too too
soon oh my god yeah like screens and
stuff get away from that i i think
i truly i mean i think social media is
drugs and um we're gonna all look back
on it and be like whoa
like everything's gonna feel like
everything we did it already for me for
me like when i look back at some of my
old posts it's like the same
feeling as like just yeah it's like
being being drunk and being like oh no i
can't believe i like
pulled that person aside and said this
thing that i never should have said and
like
you know you're doing it you're doing it
to the world to the world yeah you know
and like i don't even like i haven't
gone back and like cleaned it or
whatever like it just is what it is but
i didn't know the word thirsty like i
didn't know that term
oh like
you you wanted the attention right are
you ready
i did not know that and then um and
because like i kind of consider i don't
consider myself to be like a [ __ ] or
whatever but then i look back and i'm
like oh you're a [ __ ]
what happened with the term thirst
well just that you were third you were i
was thirsty like you don't know for who
or what but like i can't validation like
have you read yeah for sure or like just
like that i don't know what it's from i
can't remember
um
it might have been it might have been on
the you know the new show that bj novak
has
called the premise
yes
like a podcast no no it's a television
show oh oh no no i don't there it's like
all these different episodes of
different situations but there's one
about like interacting with a troll
online
and i think it's either there it's
basically like i think it's from there
that it's like even if you don't
really know who it is you're always
posting for someone aren't you
some entity some identity some end point
a cultural social
made-up endpoint and um or you're just
like oh i hope that like this person
that i like sees that you know i'm
posting that i just farted but actually
my abs are ripped
you know it's like i see a girl well
yes it's one of my favorite things the
excuses that the captions become excuses
for
um vanity for like pure vanity just like
a display of unadulterated vanity but
but the captions are meant to like kind
of mitigate that right because being
like having a bad day
boop yeah like boom
but it's a beautiful picture right
clearly like just ain't too many noodles
i just ate too many noodles like it
smells like palm trees right like
there's not a palm tree in that picture
what does that have to do with but i i
do the same i'm jenny i'll like it's
true i'll ask myself you know i'll say
there was a there was a time and i guess
i still follow this rules that well if
it's funny it's more valuable it's got
more value i mean if it's you know if i
if i uh if it's something that's kind of
pithy or funny but then you think well
no that that means i just want people to
think i'm funny it's just something i
happen to value that i think is above
physical beauty or whatever well it's
hard because you are funny and it is
part of what you do and it's part of how
you make your living and it's part of
how you exist in the world and what you
what you want to give but it it again
like everything needs its own
equilibrium and has its place like you
could meet someone a new friend and be
like man i actually like love this
person and i hope that will be best
friends but if you say that to them on
day one it's kind of weird like
everything has its time and place and i
like to be funny too it's also it's my
my bonding instinct it's something i
love about myself and it's also
something that can um you know where my
deepest insecurities also can live and
i just think for me on instagram i like
i mean i just when i got pregnant i was
like i think i want to hop off because
um
i just needed like privacy and um
suddenly things didn't feel appropriate
to me for me to be sharing and that was
a new feeling
when was that was that before
you had your child yeah like right
around i mean i still use it i and i use
it to put my work out there but i don't
look at it at all that's key i think
that's really important
we went away on a just uh
a week vacation and i put my phone down
um
like total phoneless vacation and and
for the first 48 hours it was
it like you said it's an addiction so it
was i felt the withdrawals okay you know
i felt what am i missing my my mind
wasn't settled and we were by the way on
this beautiful i could hear the waves at
night and hey
it's just
like the most beautiful surroundings and
and a couple days in um i found myself
just so much
happy so much more carefree so much more
present yeah
like noticeably so um
so i after that i tried to i'm trying to
implement uh
some of those rules into i mean as much
as i can but like you said it's hard for
work yeah like you have your you have
your career you have your podcast you
you do want people to know about it like
you know i'm writing a second book it
how will people know that that book
exists if i don't tell them and it's
sort of
so there there are a couple
things at play and i just know it's not
it's not good for me
um
to be using it anymore in a social way
or a personal way yeah and that's just
like that's just my deal but i um
i will say
there are some people's instagrams that
like i miss and
it's it's not like i i did make a hard
cut that i'm like i'm not you know doing
that but like i
i wish um i like i love watching miranda
july do her instagram oh really oh i
love her i love her books i yeah i'm
just like obsessed with everything i
mean she's so she's so incredible i
think i think she's just she's just
incredible um
but yeah i don't who else do you miss on
what other i mean like
like funny content like kind of uh yeah
there's like a farm in japan
that has like um a lot of um
[Music]
the i think they're like mini ponies
but also like they're also with pigs and
turtles and like it's like all of these
animals live together i miss that
oh yeah
you're the middle child yeah um i was
i'm a middle i was i am a middle child
uh what was your role that in that
dynamic what who were you in that was it
typical like
trying to get attention being the
peacemaker was it that i think pretty
typical
yeah like attention stuff
i think my parents gave us all um a lot
of attention but
i have always
yeah i've
i've always needed something i actually
was thinking about it this morning that
like you know they say and now i'm into
it because i have my own child but they
say like if your child's attachment to
you is unhealthy
that
if you leave
and they come back they might and if you
leave and then you come back they'll try
to punish you
for leaving basically like they'll be
standoffish sure they'll push you away
or they'll cry again you know you like
just and um
i
notice as a person because i was just
thinking i was like kind of in a like a
strange mood this morning hi aydah
oh she woke up
oh man this is my grandmother um ida is
such a cute name for a baby she's so
cute um but she can't come in here she's
with her grandmother but i i don't she
can't come in um
but she's wearing a really nice sweater
that is such a cute name i love it um
but anyway yeah i was thinking like oh i
whatever my thing is like being a middle
child or something like
i have
i definitely am still working through my
own like you know primordial attachment
issues and that like sometimes when i
miss ben
i feel like a little
um a little bit of anger
and even when he doesn't hasn't done
anything wrong so i have to be really
really careful not to be like pissed
oh my god have you seen it play out i
mean has it has it's
have you
noticed it um playing out in a way that
uh
he also noticed what was he
well
yeah he notices it i mean because i i
like get kind of like
like
i mean ultimately it's very romantic
this is the biggest difference in my
life is that like
i i mean i go to therapy like
i go you know but but and i always have
but now like i really get it i'm like in
a groove or something but that it's like
you know what you might feel pissy and
angry but there actually is a chance
that it's just you like isn't that funny
it might just be you like and as a woman
i wouldn't suggest that women just start
to say like it must just be me it's me
but for me specifically it's like oh
this is me because
we've had a lovely morning but he just
left to go take a walk with a friend and
i was like
like not at him but in me and i was like
yes nothing happened what's wrong with
you
isn't that great though to be to be
conscious of those to be mindful of that
reaction and to understand what it is
it's huge i
i know i'm going through a similar shift
and i think it got ben must really uh
appreciate your awareness of that and
you know because
it means that it's um it's safer it's a
safer place to be with somebody yeah and
it's like it's like oh
you know when i feel that first flare
then i feel despair because i'm like oh
no there's a disagreement on the horizon
like i did i didn't get what i needed or
something and it's like none of that is
that's not your destiny that's not the
destination today that's that's actually
not true
it's a story yeah yeah that's the other
thing i've been seeing but there's just
stories that you tell yourself
the thing with the um and insecurities
you mentioned one of which is is
comedy is that you enjoy being funny you
find value in that you are a very funny
person but when when have those um
insecurities when have you noticed those
insecurities the most in terms of
is it is it
rejection in in the business is it um
you had an experience on snl that was
that must have been i would imagine
would was difficult to
be on for a year
[Laughter]
i hate to bring that up very much such
positive things but in terms of growth
like how did you
how do you overcome something like that
you know you
like you can't rush it
yeah and you have to just like kind of
look at
my gosh like there's just we're all
we're all telling stories all the time
and taking them in and
um convinced that we live them as well
but we're we're really not in a
contained story like at least until we
die then it's over but like for me it it
was always like snl that's that's my
dream job i wanted and like in every way
it couldn't have worked it just didn't
work including it's like a terrible
mistake on the first episode and it's
weird to kind of keep talking about it
because it seems like i'm obsessed with
it but that said
what a um and i don't honestly like i
don't think about it that much but
my relationship to those events changes
over time and i learn more about myself
um looking back on that
public and
like stunning rejection
um
and and i'm also super grateful for it
because
yeah i shouldn't have worked there and
it would have been really bad for me to
stay out my contract
um yeah yeah even though there are lots
of nice people there and i still
you know i have like i'm still friends
with a lot of my cast
and and they support me in my work now
but but uh
it was really just one of those ones i
remember thinking how i i remember just
as a viewer as somebody who didn't know
you but just knew your work i remember
thinking there are a few times where
somebody like
um has a [ __ ]
let's let's let go you that it feels
surprising it felt like um
uh you were doing such great work on it
i mean it so just as in purely
objectively um
as an outsider i felt like that was um a
surprise that was one of the surprise
moves it was surprising to me that i did
so poorly
and like and i don't think i'm unfunny
at all but i don't think i'm suited to
that culture there
the culture and and your comedy
maybe
is belongs in a different place was that
yeah
for sure
i don't know i i think i didn't
understand how it worked and i wasn't
i wasn't
i don't think i was like an upstart or
anything but i just um
there were some things about like how
scared we were all supposed to be yeah
that
there's ida that um i
i just i like honestly kind of laughed
it off i didn't i didn't really get it
but um
i also
you know that i don't know if you've
ever felt it but like
my
sometimes my comedy most of it now
comes from
curiosity joy and like
appetite but
um sometimes it can be a social reflex
where i
like immediately i'm like
nobody here really gets why i should be
here and they don't think i'm a person
of high value and
uh that's like so brutal and i'm glad i
don't really live that way anymore but
um yes yeah it's a way of trying to um
diffuse
diffuse like a a bomb that i imagine is
somehow placed like right in my heart
yeah yeah and and like uh
there's like a heightened awareness of
status sometimes in those cultures
there's um
i know i i i i guess it's that's such a
great turning point to be okay to be
comfortable with with your place in this
industry uh but it's a thing that
everyone i almost everyone i talk to who
is in this industry on the show they've
experienced i mean that that's the thing
that you come to find is that every
everyone is struggling with these
insecurities
even the people that you thought were
like cool i mean i've always thought of
you as being like
not too cool for school but like very
cool and very comfortable
i'm cool in school
yeah you are and i am confident in my
way but like
you know i mean uh
yeah it's really annoying when when
people are like you know it's all about
confidence and it's just like
actually it's it's not it's all about
ingenuity it's all about like
understanding who you are
and um
and just trying to figure out how to
like
get get close to what you want and like
making sure that your dignity remains
intact
while you make that progress
and jim was that was that a reason why
something doing obvious child having the
success of something like obvious child
was so
[Music]
important i mean in terms of maintaining
your creative dignity and um
being perceived in a different way in
the industry for sure and you know like
and also being like always had this
sneaking suspicion that it wasn't just
made for comedy but that i you know
would like to do more dramatic acting
but
feeling like i've never been given the
chance and that can become louder than
anything why don't i'm not giving
getting the chance like whatever and
so
just to
like when you finally if you are lucky
enough to finally get that role where
you can truly stretch your legs and do
things that you've only ever imagined
your very best self doing
and you do it the the refrain of i don't
get the chance or whatever just becomes
irrelevant and like really
burdensome and you know you can i i was
able to really let that go and
there have been a
a few moments where i've just kind of
been like
well you can't tell me i didn't do it
because i did and it's not from chaos
it's from process yes yeah yeah and it
must there must be real satisfaction in
that i mean it must feel
real the real sense of like
accomplishment and peace
yeah i think so but then you want more
yeah
you know it's like hunger i had a little
dose yeah yeah
life could be a dream
[Music]
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i want to talk about the new movie yes
right we're talking about that right now
yes i want you back uh
charlie front of the show has been on
the show friend of mine um i love him
it seems that way you guys have such
great chemistry
had you known him before um or was that
something that you cultivated during the
shooting i didn't know him before
um we were both in this movie um that
drew pierce directed called hotel
artemis it's a much different film very
violent um we play
totally i play like a police person in
the future and he plays like a big jerk
um
classic charlie come on um classic jenny
but yeah
and um
um
and so we met on this movie
and
i mean like i just i just admire him so
much and he's he's so good at acting
it's not just the comedy he's just
excellent all around
and he's so nice
a nice really good person like one of i
know i've known charlie for 25 i think
years
since since she kind of talked like that
he had a very unique voice
one of those people that i imagine
and as are you i mean funny um easy to
get along with i i just it's so fun to
watch you two
like each other to watch you two play
off of each other and um
i don't want to spoil anything for
people but it's uh it's also a very
unique
take on a romantic comedy it's it's um
yeah
i haven't seen that that device used
before people
i don't know if you've experienced
anything like that i mean you're
probably sick of
uh
answering that but but um
you know if you've ever
plotted not plotted but like really like
made an effort to like get somebody to
get somebody back and i guess it's sort
of like what we're talking about you
come to realize that
you know it's a lot it's a lot simpler
than that you can't force something no
it's the things that are easy that you
should really invest in no i i yeah i
don't like our movie is about two people
who get dumped and then meet in a
stairwell where they're they're both
crying and then they they just decide to
become friends and help themselves help
each other through the breakups and just
you know say to each other like look if
you're gonna call her call me instead
and i'll talk you down and you do the
same for me and then when they actually
become friends um they hatch a really
ill-advised plan to try to break up
their ex's new relationships and
convince those exes to go back with you
know with their
with no no
how
[Laughter]
but played in a very grounded way um who
i i'm so curious who some of your heroes
were your comedy the people that really
inspired you comedically when you were
growing up who
was it was it snl was it um
i'm picturing like gilda radner yeah
definitely gilda of course but it really
runs the gamut it was like you know
gilda but it was peewee
um
you know like majorly peewee i was
obsessed with peewee and i still am and
i think that energy and also like the
sort of homemade art element of it like
that it's kind of crafty um
yeah you know is really uh it's kind of
kitsch
some of your videos are like that i love
those yeah yeah
that's true it is kind of like my thing
um but then i really loved madeline khan
and um carol burnett and
um bernard peters yeah i like those sexy
ladies like i i always liked that like
that um bernadette peters like had like
this like gorgeous
figure and was she just was so oozy like
she was just oozing something and and
she was so so talented and um
yeah but then in the church capable of
being like a real
innocent not dumb but like hilariously
like innocent again
well you you have some of that jenny i
can understand you being um
inspired by those people yeah uh what
what are you what are you saying you're
writing a book then no another book yeah
yeah
it's like in the very early stages
okay okay well then we shan't talk about
it but we have to come back on and i
will be
extra early um when you do come back on
i will promise you that uh jen i just
have like a lightning round yeah really
quick yeah um what is your favorite
emoji
oh your go-to
most commonly used i like the swan
[Laughter]
head was not expecting that yeah i have
not heard that i don't even know if i
knew there was this one well there is
yeah okay
that's awesome uh who was your first
celebrity crush
uh probably gene kelly
gene kelly wow yeah we watched a lot of
movies from like the
library uh yes we did too yes the
library vhs um
and what is your favorite ice cream
flavor
um
jesus
it's really hard
i love jesus that tastes good to me um
you know i'm i'm i'm really into like
the cherry garcia right now oh yeah of
ben and jerry's i really like that but
i'm also into sunday's full-on oh wow
that's what we've been doing
really
yeah like a hot fudge sundae
with vanilla ice cream
um what is your favorite holiday
thanksgiving
okay um
and did you have it out here did you
have it you know we have it in our house
in massachusetts oh man okay uh what is
what is your uh what is a movie that an
acclaimed movie that people
you're embarrassed to admit you haven't
seen that people kind of shame you for
not having seen
um
i haven't seen avatar
oh okay but no one like shames me
no they're just like well then you can't
see it now
yeah you know you can't like watch it in
your house i guess or something
i i wonder if it would hold up um
yeah i wonder if it does hold up i
haven't seen it in so long what is yeah
that's not one that you need to see what
is a game show pastor president that
you'd want to be a contestant on
oh
um
a game show that's fun
um
i
a wheel of fortune
oh yeah that seems so fun oh my god i'd
love to spin the wheel and i think i'd
be really good at it
i also love pat sajak i think pat sajak
is so good at what he does so great and
you but you know let me say one other
thing that's just related is that i
sometimes don't even understand what the
categories are on jeopardy let alone
know the information and like they're
like
drinkable
laughing
potable like wait what and then the
person like bleep blinks the beeper or
whatever and they're like who is
napoleon and you're like i don't know
i'm completely dumbest person
my brother christian and he's so good at
jeopardy um
and sometimes i find myself as he's
saying the answer i'll kind of say it on
top of him it's this brotherly thing
that you kind of have to like it's this
competitive brotherly thing where you
have to like let them know that you also
knew
um
it's really immature um
coffee or tea and if so how do you take
it i drink coffee in the morning and i
take it with a little bit of half and
half and sometimes in the afternoon i'll
have some tea
oh half and half nice
you know i don't hear that often zoe
deschanel yesterday said um heavy cream
that's her that's nice
heavy
um if you could learn another language
what would it be
norwegian
oh cool for real it's a beautiful bubbly
language i sort of started it and then i
like didn't i didn't do it oh yeah wow
um and what is your favorite cereal
jenny oh oh
oh oh i like um
[Music]
i guess right now i really like cinnamon
toast crunch
but like the organic one like the
cascadian farms or whatever yes the
pleasant valley yes
yes yes not quite the same but um you uh
if you had to choose a different first
name what would it be
oh like maybe something kind of french
like
odette oh oh ted that's a nice name yeah
cody rosa is a lovely name
rosa yeah i like that name rosa slaves
that's nice uh if that goes with ida
that goes well with ida um if you had a
sandwich named after you uh
the jenny slate sandwich what would be
on okay you get it at the bodega
okay late night
um you have to get you don't they only
oh yeah no it's not an all-day thing and
it is perfect and it is um on a roll
you're gonna get not smoked turkey but
just like turkey with american cheese
um frank's red hot mayo shredded lettuce
um shredded it's gotta be shredded
jalapeno peppers and
one thin sliced tomato
wow delicious that sounds so good what
is your favorite tom hanks movie
all of them i just love them so much i
just love him so much but i guess it is
sleepless in seattle
yes christians as well uh quick would
you rather take a time machine in the
past or the future to the past
uh are you more of a talker or a texter
oh
i'm really equally both
beach or mountains [ __ ]
roll over
wait what i don't know
but i know that whenever it's wrong like
whatever it is
when it feels i'm like wait what
yeah
you know like something's wrong you
don't know what it is that's what it is
yes something's missed but i don't know
what it is it's like how i don't like
you know how like someone someone was
like ariana grande only likes her face
being photographed on one side or
something i heard that oh really like
three years ago and i've been thinking
about it because i'm like what do i am i
missing out on something like is there a
side that's better
i would love to know
have you studied have you looked did you
did it compel you to look i mean the
second i look in the mirror i'm like oh
god and then i stopped whoa
um and lastly if you would finish this
sentence life is short so
be very sweet to yourself
yeah well you've been very sweet to be
impatient here i wish we had more time
just i know
jenny i am so sorry for earlier you are
so sweet to do this i i'm such a fan of
yours i cannot i can't wait to read your
new book and we're going to talk all
about i want you back we're going to
just sing its praises please do i hope
you let me come back on another time i
really liked this i love talking to you
likewise jenny i would love that i would
love it when it's when i'm on time and
and set up properly uh you were so kind
to do this i truly really love your work
and always same right back at you right
back let's talk again okay thanks justin
oh that's the lovely item i'm so happy
for you
is she coming into the room she's
outside with her grandmother now oh
sweet sweet i have a blast just at the
best time
thank you for doing this
[Music]
so so that just happened whoa so that
just just happened
she's got um so that just happened yeah
there's a
how's that it's very hard to do she's
got such a unique voice
yes yes yes queen she has a she has a
great
like animation voice obviously laughs
and she's got like a kind of a raspy she
has the kind of voice where
she could
i would easily believe her as a
four-year-old or a 90-year-old yes you
know yes yes yes yes she can go in
either direction so easily that's true
there's a real child like quality and
which i think in older voices there can
be i guess
it's that and she's she's got such a
versatile voice she does a lot of
characters on yeah big mouth and you
could see like how not on big mouth
anymore oh she's not yes
she uh stepped aside because you don't
remember this it was a big story yes all
right it's a big story she was a big
monster she was
uh playing a person of color oh man on
the show and she um she's not a person
of color she's not a person of color so
she left the show
to be replaced by a
voice belonging to a person a voice of
color a voice of color can you say that
a voice of color probably not
jenny slate is um by the way how late
were you yeah you apologized
i was quite late
yes because i oh it was so
frustrating i didn't like more than five
minutes it sounded like 15 minutes oh
okay it was 15 minutes
you had like verging on 20 minutes you
had like 35 minutes late it was
apologetic energy well here's the
problem once i got it started i realized
there were other things that i hadn't
done you know so like
so i was scrambling as she was saying
such great stuff she was talking about
and very like frankly talking about her
postpartum and
you know having a child it was such good
stuff and i was like oh i don't want to
like because she thought i was all ready
uh because i had the thing on oh so you
didn't get any of that
i didn't get any of that but it was but
then she kind of repeated i asked her
again about it um but it was you know
what it was it was this stupid you know
these
[ __ ] little uh
buttons these what do you call plugs
input things they keep changing computer
by computer
so i didn't have the attachment for the
yeti
which is why sorry listeners it sounds
maybe a little bit more i sound a little
bit more echoey than i usually do you
love our yeti microphone the irony that
you were the mac guy continues to pay
dividends
it's so it it you and technology
it's it's oil and water and it really
triggers me too because um and i don't
use that word often maybe do i trigger
you oh okay well well it depends what
you mean by often yeah i but it it
affects me um in a way that i i don't
think others are as affected by because
i've just had such a bad relationship
with technology are you
worried that you say trigger too often
because you don't want to co-opt that
term that's often used for more
seriously maybe maybe like for
really
just hit the microphone
that was the equivalent that was the
microphone tapping equipment equivalent
of someone who's walking down the
sidewalk and they triple and they say
sorry to the and they look back at the
little crack or whatever they're like
kind of blaming yes the crack that they
just did i like that yeah
god
those are the moments where like i
realize what you're tr what a true nerd
i am
like because it's just natural it's just
yeah you know what you know who's never
done something like that before it
sounds like scott eastwood
you know what i mean fine
that all right hey one of the actors in
jenny slate's new movie i want you back
yes jenny slate's new movie is um a
romantic comedy
co-starring
friend of the show charlie charlie
they're love charlie they're both
so good together mm-hmm
and like and that's something that i
liked about the movie is that you really
root for them to end up together because
individually they're so likable yes
but then they're they're other but they
have such great chemistry together so do
you find yourself thinking why don't you
just be together i found myself thinking
you should get over scott eastwood
really quickly and go be with charlie
well i guess they felt like for nothing
against scott eastwood i don't know him
but but she had this magical chemistry
with charlie day yeah well maybe they're
thinking just superficially scott
eastwood is like the classically
handsome of course yeah
and then charlie day is with gina
rodriguez yes yeah yeah well yeah those
two together i can imagine they're
they're both so you know what it is
they're so
funny it's it's really enjoyable to
watch fun funny people be together and
make each other laugh i'm thinking the
opposite is true of
this season's bachelor
oh yeah it's really
um because they've been i i have to say
that the bachelorettes the last ever
since like rachel lindsay was very
bright and funny and and the last few
have been
i felt like that's the direction they've
been going oh the lap michelle was great
yeah and um well i'm trying to think of
the last the last
i know uh
um well
i'll tell you what colton looks a lot
more impressive comparably compared to
this
to clayton i don't mean anything by
their like pers by their um characters i
i don't mean just like how they are on
dates like how they are as as
conversationalists just better
personality yeah i i if you don't want
to say it i'll say it
just more interesting more fun more
funny kind of like uh there's just he
seems nice nice but kind of boring
you know i know but yeah it's it's a
good movie mostly because they're
they're so good together yeah two now
friends of the show yeah we have a lot
of friends on the show we sure do yes
jenny's you know what it is too is um
she's so
uh present she's one of those people
that's just like really listens well
she's a good listener she's um she's a
little bit like female you you know i
think of that seinfeld episode with
janine grofflow
when it's like they're like dating each
other and they're like oh we're the same
person yeah it's a little bit you have a
lot in common certainly yeah
like neurotic and we have similar
neurons fidgety and funny and like
you're both middle children and yeah um
but
here's a difference she quit smoking
weed which i was very surprised to learn
i know because i associated her with
smoking weed for for so long me too me
too i didn't nick kroll talk about that
too that he had stopped and i was like i
think so um i know i she had such a kind
of stoner quality yes
yeah i know that was surprising
why did she do it again she i think she
she had a lack of empathy yeah she was
feeling um it was making her paranoid
and and yeah just
too neurotic wait you know what's when i
hear people say that especially somebody
like jenny who i like so much and i feel
could benefit from
cannabis uh ingestion i i find myself
arguing on its behalf on unlike the
benefits of it and and that maybe she
had the wrong strain or she should
experiment with something like a
different type of yeah but that's true
but remember everyone everyone's
different everyone's different everyone
like physiologically everyone reacts to
we differently like
i mean i know that for me if i have i
can only have small doses of it because
if i have any more than a small dose
yeah i like get so stuck in my head and
i
not only do i not have a good time on it
i i have like a really bad time well i
noticed recently i just came back from
utah and uh i've been working there and
i hadn't been
uh using
using weed
smoking weed i wasn't not just smoking
but eating i hadn't been having
adjusting
there was i had no weed for like a
couple weeks while i was working and i
found
um i have to say like i i was much
sharper yeah i was it does affect your
short-term memory it does it does and
like i think that's part of the fun for
me is like it helps me kind of like
check out and be less stressed and be
more present to um just enjoying them
you know just enjoying the moment and
not having not having stuff in my head
swirling around but um when it comes to
work and productivity yeah i think it
it's good for me to take little breaks
and i get why jenny maybe well you just
did a 180. i know i know i know because
i just you're like i want to talk her
into smoking more yeah also smoking less
allows you more uh 180s in your life
well it allows you to see the big
picture yeah both sides yes both sides
of the coin but it also makes it also
makes when you do then return to weed if
i do it makes it more enjoyable because
your body my body at a certain point
like during the pandemic i
had built up a real tolerance for it
well the same with anything same with
drinking if you don't drink for a while
and you have a beer it's like you get
such a fun buzz that's true if you're
drinking a lot you have to like remember
those when we used to play darts with
keir in his house
like back in the day 10 15 years ago we
used to drink so many beers just
casually i know and i remember nights
would go by we just and playing darts
and hanging out and be like like six
seven beers and like you wouldn't feel
anything no isn't that crazy not proud
of this no and now six six beers now
would like knock it knocked me off for
like two days
i know do you know what's weird about
what you just i 10 15 years ago you said
i just saw on twitter
um not proud that i'm looking at twitter
but i just saw that it was that today is
the 13th or maybe it was yesterday who
cares 13th anniversary of the release of
he's just not that into you and i
thought
god 13 years and remember we went to
that you at the premiere we went back to
drew's and it was like this i remember
that night how crazy that was 13 years
ago i can't believe that was 13 years no
13 years that was a fun night yeah i
know but it all kind of came flooding
back uh and i think and put everything
in perspective too because then you
think like that was 13 years ago then 13
years before that was
god we were tina we were just on the
cusp of like
adolescence
you know what i i i
thought yesterday or the day before that
i'm closer now oh these scare me don't
do this i'm closer now to being 60 yeah
than 20. oh man is that weird yeah
yeah it is
uh hey should we read a letter yes
okay i want you back oh sorry one of
those is uh not the letter hmm
the second one oh oh yeah oh okay that's
for our later interview which i'm not
going to say because i don't know good
yeah no spoiler i don't spoil it from
melissa hill
subject knight name you can pronounce
yes you're nice and easy isn't that nice
to like well it's rare it's not not to
suggest that
no but for you you have such a hard time
with certain names i do melissa hill
what if she's like it's melissa
subject 90 day fiance cameo
hi justin and christian i love listening
to your podcast while i doordash oh a
doordasher
cool you know that app yes yeah okay
you're just looking at me with confusion
um i was thinking about 90 day fiance oh
oh okay yeah you look like you were
somewhere else yeah sorry
i was thinking about uh the potential
podcast yeah so chris and i have an idea
for um yeah so we're drumming up an idea
for a 90-day fiance podcast a re-watch
yeah um but i
don't know that's good to you right but
if it doesn't come to fruition um
we just have a 90-day fiance segment
yeah that's true um i love listening to
your podcast while i doordash and they
really make my time fly by and also
cause me to get funny looks from other
when i'm cracking up while i'm driving
that's funny um that's nice too funny
and nice i remember hearing you say on a
previous podcast how you got a cameo
from a 90-day contestant sure did and i
don't remember which
it was yeah well two now well i got you
one you got me one
you got me one from coltie yeah and i
got you one from zedd yes yes yes yes
happy birth
justin oh larissa yeah oh the
colton's was amazing not caught in cold
cold yeah
colton
oh colton i was thinking happy birthday
christian yes yes very conspiratorial
yeah
that's amazing anyway back to melissa i
thought you may be interested to know
that a couple of years ago i got a cameo
from paul and karine
i remember that you do for my sister's
birthday before they went balls to the
wall cuckoo for cocoa pops so paul was
nuts i did do i did i see that maybe not
maybe you didn't serve that season i
remember that season i can reach out to
her to see if she still has it he was
doing this weird running down the
hallway thing and hinting at a possible
pregnancy it was insane let me know if
you'd like me to get a hold of it and
forward it to you i guarantee you will
laugh your asses off also i've been
telling you i've been telling everyone
to watch lady at the manor all right
and my dad told me last night he watched
it and loved it yes yes double yes thank
you melissa and thank you mr hill
that's awesome
uh here's a isn't that nice to hear yeah
it's funny i don't
have the same it's just such a different
thing than like
just acting i mean it's just well
whatever because it's the whole thing is
different i get it yeah okay back to
melissa here's a would you rather
would you rather have to have a very
visible tattoo with a word misspelled
that always has to be on display
or you have to very loudly announce
whenever you go to the bathroom which
function you're going to do in there
loud enough for everyone nearby to hear
you well
let me just say
i often do do the second one as a joke
like i i've been doing i was doing this
on
set um
just recently where i'd say
i'd asked brent shout out to brent the
first id awesome guy great first ad
brent would say um
i would say hey brian i i got to go to
the bat i have to go ten i have to go to
the bathroom and and in the movie world
in a lot of worlds it's ten one is
peeing and ten two is pooing
and so and so i'd say it's a ten one uh
that may turn into a ten two i'll let
you know i'll keep you posted uh and if
it's a 10-3 i'm going to keep it to
myself that's funny um wait did she say
you have to loudly say yeah you have to
very loudly announce whenever you go to
the bathroom which function wait very
loudly yeah which i'm trying to wrap my
head around which function you're gonna
do in there which you're going to do in
there okay so you'd have to be like
i mean it's a number one it's gonna be a
number one
all right but you don't have to say
number one you could be like
i have to go defecate but you have to
yell it yes
you do that
um is that the end of the question
yes i and oh she says i.e she i.e you're
at a dinner party with network
executives and you get up and loudly
announced i'm going to poop now
i mean see that's the situation where it
would be more
difficult i suppose but why not or
you're just the eccentric see i could
get away with it because it's like oh
he's like the eccentric actor guy yeah
also
if it's a dinner party a situation like
that where you really
or like you're meeting
your girlfriend's grandmother for the
first time really easy for me i know but
like if if it imagine a scenario that
that would be really like you're at a
state dinner you're at a wink you're
right yeah that or you're actually
wouldn't go or you're at like a u.n
dinner oh i'd hold it if i'm that's what
i'm saying yeah you would just
strategically not drink
water or wine or whatever yeah not have
the occasion to go to the bathroom
that's what i would do or i would say
hey u.n i have to go take a puan
in the
in the restroom so stupid um
i wouldn't hold it
if i were there well okay for there's a
lot to unpack it first of all
the tattoo oh if it has to be visible
i'm imagining neck on your neck let's
say and if it's a word that's misspelled
think about a word that's like
obviously depends on the word but let's
say it's a word
that's like kind of one of those douchey
like you know faux spiritual like um
like free like karma freedom is good
like fredo yeah and if freedom is
misspelled to f-r-e-d-o-m that would be
so embarrassing what if it's ironic what
if it's the word like accuracy spelled
with a k
that's different because then it looks
um deliberate yeah but you could do that
a word misspelled that i know but i'm a
match but then you're like the best
version of this hypothetical i'm
imagining something that looks
uh um like it was an accident you know
yeah uh oh you or the word accident with
a ks you know next alex deliberate i
think freedom's gonna fredham or karma
spelled uh-huh uh like k-h like khaki
mm-hmm
you know something like
or not like i'm trying to think of other
ironic ones like regret
but see that's that looks like it it's
on purpose yeah but but that's according
to this hypothetical that could you
could that's an option then i would do
that you would yeah because i don't want
i don't mind announcing in 99 of the of
my life
i wouldn't be embarrassed to say
i have to go defecate
but i don't i wouldn't want to have to
do it i know you're right you're right
well
a very a very she says very visible
tattoo so yeah it'd have to be on your
neck i mean if your face i don't want a
face i don't want to face that too
can you imagine i can't believe postman
how do you ask somebody that like i'm
just imagining having post malone on the
show and being like
when what was the line like did you have
tattoos i'm imagining post malone being
on the show and you struggling not to
ask him that question i have to i know i
mean because i i would imagine it would
start with like a teardrop or some sort
of maybe not a teardrop i think that
means you killed somebody yeah uh
at some sort of like tiny mark on your
face
what percentage of people with face
tattoos do you think got their first
tattoo on the face
it's got to be less than one right yeah
i mean much less like who has machine
gun kelly has uh yeah you don't start
with the face oh my god i keep getting
machine gun kelly content on my
instagram me too
me too i feel like i clicked on one
article about megan to get a lot of
machine
months ago i clicked on one article
about megan fox washington and kelly and
now it's like constantly dominating the
newspaper pda did you see the thing
where it's like they're engaging in um
couples pda no it would oh man it was
her it's they do couples pda is the new
thing now it's like so it's uh who's the
drummer for blink 182. travis barr
travis barker's dating one of the cards
i knew that too i learned that because
the machine machine gun well i guess
they're couple friends you know what and
they could do pda in front of paper oh
my god but like not like kind of
intimate it's like they're like tonguing
they like lash tongues to each other oh
god we it could be that we mentioned
machine gun kelly on an earlier episode
of this yeah and maybe our phones are
listening maybe we you know it's on the
podcast and yeah and i subscribe to this
podcast oh so maybe yeah maybe i don't
know oh that knows how connected it is
yeah it's definitely the case in fact
julia duffy shout out uh wonderful
actress in the movie we just did uh she
said oh my phone i was my phone just
like kept popping up your podcast life
show kept popping up that's when she
listened to it maybe out of annoyance
like okay i'll listen um but she's
probably i said well probably because
you've been talking to me and or about
and saying maybe talking to your husband
about it or whatever
um
i remember a machine gun kelly we were
shooting lady the manor the the bar the
bar scene
um shout out to the pelican pub yes i
remember the proprietor of that place
right she was walking us around and
showing us around and she said you know
machine gun kelly played here oh yes and
i remember saying who i didn't know him
i never it didn't even ring a bell
looked at me like i had a penis growing
out of my forehead yes
and now i know him so well because i'm
constantly getting his contacts i know i
had never heard of him i know it's as if
you had said um i'm sorry what's the
statue of liberty yeah it was like that
yeah she's like
i know she was incredulous
anyway i would pick the um
the machine gun i would pick the uh
announcing of the bathroom visits
i don't want to face tattoos don't
either if it's face if it's neck i could
it'd be closer fredham
fredom i don't want freda on my neck i'd
rather say
i'm going pee i know but it just depends
how loud it would be annoying to have to
yell for that time i mean i also was
like it's a good question though it is a
good question they're both such
different things yeah they're equally
really yes annoying yep yep yeah because
i was also thinking the practicality of
always having to do it always having to
because i you know you pee and me pee
and poo a lot but on on road trips i see
i would i would then have to do it i
guess this wouldn't be that bad for a
lot of people but i don't want to when
i'm like in public oftentimes i don't
want to call attention to myself
you know i don't want to have to say i
don't want people to be like because
that would especially out at a
restaurant like you go to the bathroom
you just have to be more strategic about
it yeah that'd be annoying though it
would every restaurant you'd have to
yell at everyone will look at you you
might have you might have to pick the
tattoo i might have to yeah but then i
get to pick the word that's misspelled
oh okay okay
all right
huh what would you pick
i don't have to think about it all right
freedom's good free adam or like
or like uh some what's another like faux
spiritual like um like spirituality like
inner peace but like yeah he's spelled
wrong yes like pi but people might think
that people might think that's an iron
that's true it's tricky it's it's a
tricky um
karma thread karma's with a c no or k a
c looks more deliberate h k h a r m a
like
yeah yeah um or something related to the
neck uh what if it's just neck tattoo or
buddha and just butter
but that's funny
all right well anyway we digress uh back
to melissa thanks for all the laughs
thank you for the letter melissa melissa
in pennsylvania quote and her quote cool
from willy wonka we are the makers of
music and we are the dreamers of dreams
i love that i have a confession to make
you've never seen it no wow you would
love it i'm sure thanks melissa thank
you melissa letter if you guys would
like to write into the show our email
address is lifeshortwandery.com
and uh thank you to ever thank you jenny
too and looking forward to her new book
and check out her new movie with friend
of the show charlie day i want you back
um and check out all of her stuff she's
she does it all she does and she's good
at all of it man oh we're really glad i
got to i'm glad i i'm not glad i wasn't
um
so embarrassingly late but she did say
sweetly too we were texting she said um
you know i'd love to do it again and
like what so when her book comes out she
is somebody that i would love to have
back on because there's just too much to
talk to her about yeah she's cool she's
cool um so thanks jenny and thanks
everyone for listening and we'll talk to
you next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted
and co-produced by you christian long
and it's also produced by megan the
monaco and katie the allen senior
producer is michelle miesh lans audio
engineer is i just saw him recently
looks great everyone sergio enriquez and
the executive producer
wondering yeah wondering yeah bye
[Music]
i've never dealt with a 14 and a half
inch neck that was not a child
said olga
i'm so tired
no no i love it
it's um it's honest
it's honest
i didn't know what you meant by that the
size of my neck
so it's it's
surprisingly small is what you're saying
it's all looking it's elegant elegance
okay thank you
you